we've been testing the 20/20 iPad pro
for about two weeks and we've made quite
a few different comparison videos with
this new iPad and to be honest I was a
bit disappointed when I compared it to
the 2018 iPad pro I found a total of
just seven differences between the two
and most of them are small differences
the addition of the ultra wide camera
upgraded microphone quality six gigs of
ram across the board
Wi-Fi six a hundred and twenty eight
gigs of storage on the base model the
new lidar scanner and the switch to the
a 12 z chip so with such a limited
amount of changes it quickly became
apparent that those who already own the
2018 model should absolutely not upgrade
to the 2020 iPad pro so it makes you
wonder why did Apple even release such a
small update to the iPad pro instead of
just holding off for the rumored mini
LED model well we're gonna take a look
at the new iPad pro from an honest point
of view and see why it makes sense for
Apple to release it but before that
let's go through each of those seven
differences in how much I personally
think each of the matters starting with
the new ultra wide camera to be honest
it doesn't matter to me at all I take my
photos with my iPhone which already has
an ultra wide lens so I feel like Apple
just added this in to make the large
square camera bump look similar to
recent iPhones onto the microphone
quality this is actually something that
could be useful for anyone doing online
zoom meetings or for those who want to
record podcasts or anything like that
however the 2018 model still sounds
pretty decent here's a quick comparison
between the two this is a microphone
quality tests on the 2018 iPad pro this
is a microphone quality tests on the
20/20 iPad pro I'm glad that Apple
decided to give the 20/20 iPad pro 6
gigabytes of RAM since a major focus of
the iPad is now multitasking so this is
one of the biggest advantages compared
to the other iPads in the lineup this
will definitely help for productivity
work like photo and video editing as
well
however I never really notice any
problems with four gigs of memory on the
2018 model but it also didn't push
multitasking as much as some others
could the switch to Wi-Fi six is a nice
little addition but it's important to
note that it really only makes a
difference if your house is set up with
the Wi-Fi six internet router so if you
don't plan on getting one of these
routers any time soon then it really
shouldn't matter to you and it's also
likely that a lot of coffee shops and
other businesses don't yet have Wi-Fi
six routers installed now the bump up to
128 gigs of storage is probably the
biggest deal that you'll notice daily
since there were a lot of people who
bought the base 64 gig 2018 iPad pro as
a laptop replacement and then realized
that it was extremely limiting so I
think 128 gigs of storage is gonna help
a lot for storing files apps photos and
games now the lidar scanner is a very
interesting addition because it greatly
improves the accuracy of object and
depth tracking which is used for
augmented reality apps however there
just aren't very many compelling air
apps out right now so chances are you
won't have much use for it for a while
but I think Apple is actually looking
towards the future by adding lidar more
on that in just a minute the final
difference is the switch to the a 12 Z
processor and in my personal opinion I
think the reason we're not seeing a
significantly upgraded a 13 X chip is
because Apple knows that the current a
12 X processor in the 2018 iPad pro is
already miles ahead of every other
tablet on the market and to this day
that chip is still overkill in terms of
performance even the best apps and games
out there aren't yet able to use it to
its full potential
so why upgraded Apple figure that they
should keep this chip around for another
year but if they kept the same a 12 X
name people would get pretty upset and
would it buy it so they change the name
and slightly improve the chip by adding
one more active course of the graphics
just to make the appearance that it's a
new chip and to be honest this marketing
technique actually works since a lot of
these upgrades don't matter very much
for a lot of consumers a lot of people
are looking to buy the
18 iPad pro on sale instead currently
the base 2018 model is listed for $700
on Amazon which is only $100 cheaper
than the 2020 iPad pro and the main
difference between the two is the jump
from 64 gigs of storage to 128 and I
personally think that this change alone
makes it worth the extra $100 simply
because of the fact that 64 gigs is
cutting it way too close if you plan on
doing anything but basic web browsing
and gaming on it and then you also have
to consider the other improvements like
6 gigs of ram and the fact that it's the
2020 model and it feels good to have the
latest model which some people don't
like to admit but it's true now I know a
lot of people are looking forward to the
new mini LED iPad pro with the a 14 X
chip that's rumored to be coming this
fall but I honestly don't think it's
coming in till at least spring time next
year it just doesn't make sense for
Apple to update the iPad pro twice
within six months so now let's get into
why I think Apple released such a small
update to the iPad pro instead of
waiting another year and also why I
think Apple chose to update those seven
things that seem insignificant by
themselves first off if Apple didn't
update the iPad pro this year it would
ultimately be bad for sales imagine if a
brand new 20/20 Samsung Galaxy Tab s7
gets released and people have to choose
between that in a two year old iPad pro
the 20/20 tablet just sounds better
so they updated it but they didn't
change very much since the 2018 model
was already the best and most powerful
tablet out there what I personally
believe makes the iPad pro so great this
year is actually the new iPad OS
software here's an old clip from my very
first review of the 11 inch iPad pro
only a couple of weeks after its release
before the introduction of iPad OS so
it's not that Apple can't add Mouse
support to the iPad it's because they
don't want to Apple may continue adding
computer-like features here and there
but the iPad pro will never be a true
laptop replacement until Apple wants it
to be so now a year and a half later
Apple has finally made the decision to
market
iPad pro as a modern laptop replacement
and it achieves this goal by using a
combination of a few different things
namely the new multitasking features in
iPad OS like the more capable splitview
mode and in-depth app control the
ability to hook up an external storage
drive and drag and drop files right onto
the iPad within the files app and
especially the recent addition of cursor
and trackpad support for the iPad
now you might be thinking all of the
other iPads and the lineup also have the
same exact software features and yes
they do but the iPad pro does it better
it's got crazy amounts of power it's got
double the RAM for multitasking it's got
the USB C port for much easier file
transfers it's got the latest and
fastest Wi-Fi specs and it's got one
more thing that Apple is betting big on
this year support for their brand new
magic keyboard case that's coming this
made I believe that this magic keyboard
case is going to be seriously great and
disruptive to the portable computing
world and Apple knows it it might seem
insane that they think they can price it
at a massive 300 dollars and still sell
a bunch of them but I think that when
people get their hands on it
the reviews are gonna be so positive
that within a year it'll be a rare sight
to see a new iPad pro without the new
magic keyboard case that's because it's
got the perfect combination of features
that are basically the final piece of
the laptop replacement puzzle including
pass-through charging which essentially
frees up the main USB C port for things
like transferring files a high quality
built-in trackpad that works perfectly
with the new cursive support a keyboard
that finally gets backlighting and
laptop level scissor switch keys
directly from the 16 inch MacBook Pro
and lastly a brand new floating ipad
design that's so unique and original
that is going to take the market by
storm and the best part about it is that
it also supports the 2018 iPad pro model
as well so Apple doesn't necessarily
want users with the 2018 model to
upgrade to the 2020 model they simply
want them to buy the new magic keyboard
case and I believe that the combination
of the latest iPad OS software features
the great performance of the iPad pro
and the
magic keyboard case are gonna create the
ultimate laptop replacement this is
gonna cause a lot of people to choose an
iPad pro instead of a macbook and
apple's totally okay with it
because the ipad pro with the magic
keyboard case costs just about the same
as one of their entry-level mac books
especially if you get extra storage or
you go for the twelve point nine inch
model so in the end apple is winning and
the cherry on top for the iPad pro is
that I'm a hundred percent sure that
Apple's gonna announce a lot of new
changes and features to iPad OS at this
year's WWDC that are gonna be focused on
making the iPad an even better laptop
replacement and this is also where the
lidar scanner comes in while it doesn't
make much sense right now
Apple is most likely going to announce
some pretty massive changes and new
features to augmented reality that just
might spark the beginning of a are
becoming much more popular and when it
does you're gonna want a lidar scanner
on your Apple device so there you guys
have it that's apples master plan with
the new 20/20 iPad pro which admittedly
is more focused on the magic keyboard
case in iPad OS software than it is on
the 20/20 model since the 2018 iPad pro
reaps basically all of the same benefits
this is bit of a team with Mac stack and
if you enjoy this review go ahead and
tap the like button and click the circle
above for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]